[Music]
so let's say you have some NLP solution
for several languages maybe you have a
named entity recognition solution or
sentiment analysis solution and now you
would like to support more languages but
you don't have any training data
available and some of you might know of
many of you probably know that it's
really expensive to acquire and it takes
time to get your data training data
sorry but what you do have is raw data
so this talk is going to be about how
can you expand your solution to new
languages using transfer learning and
I'm going to explain it to you on an
example of City parsing tasks that we
are trying to solve a text kernel so as
I already told an internet external and
a text kernel we match people and jobs
and CV parsing is the core of our
solution so we solve CV parsing in three
stages first we do section segmentation
so during section segmentation we
extract sections so we extract for
example personal section experience
section education section and then other
sections as well then follows item
segmentation so during item segmentation
within each section we extract items so
for example from experience section you
can extract first experience and second
experience and then during the last
stage phrase extraction we extract
phrases so for example from experience
section you can extract phrases like job
title organization location or from
education section you can extract degree
or university and this talk is going to
be about phrase extraction and in
particular I'm going to talk about
phrase extraction from experience
section and I'm going to show it to you
an example of German and English
languages so see percentiles can be
formulated as a second sequence labeling
task and you can think about it as of
something similar to named entity
recognition and to solve this task we
use by Alisa TM plus CRF architecture if
you want to read more about the
architecture I would highly recommend
you to read the paper by hung at all or
you can also have a look at our talk
by data in London 2018 but this is how
it works in a nutshell so you have words
and then you get embeddings from those
words and then then you pass it to the
biology layers and on the tip you have
CRF layer and then in the end you
extract the entity so you have location
name phone and others so let me tell you
how it all started it index kernel we
now support 20 languages and new
languages are coming and we want to
support more languages but we don't have
label data for those languages and it
takes time to get it so what we want to
have instead is we want to have a
multilingual model that will allow us to
power several languages at the same time
and we hope that this will help us to
implement new models for new languages
as fast as possible and also improve
performance on low resource languages
using transfer learning and cross
lingual embeddings so what are cross
lingual embeddings crust lingual
embeddings word representations that
capture two main things
so first we want semantically similar
words in the same language to be nearby
so you can see how Julie and University
German we want this to be close by and
then we also want translational
equivalents in different languages to be
close by for example you want to
premiere in Durban and programmer in
English to be mapped close to each other
so there are several ways how you can
get Christine will embeddings the first
one is you can just download cross
lingual embeddings and I can highly
recommend you to have a look at this
muse github repository this is a
Facebook project and they have 30
languages there and then I put all in
the shared space and actually if you use
this you already get quite good results
but the problem with using pre-trained
embeddings is that normally they are
trained on some generic data so they
either use news articles or they use
Wikipedia articles so they're quite
generic and they might not work for your
domain specifically also they might not
have the language
that you want to implement in your
product specifically so if you want to
do transfer knowledge from Russian to
Slovene for example you might not find
it in the news so what you can do
instead you can use the open-source
alignment code and what you would do
then you would first trade monolingual
embedding separately for all the
languages you want and you will use your
domain data to do that and then you will
use the alignment code to map it all in
the same space and there are different
solutions available online that you can
just check out the first one is the
bilingual solution this is the project
called Trek map and they map two
languages into shared space
and then there are also multilingual
solutions like multilingual fast text
you-you-you MWe
or CCA and they map multiple languages
to the same language or to the shared
space and a text kernel we are now for
our research use PRC solution and I'm
gonna explain you in a second why we'll
find this one good so CCA is canonical
correlation analysis and this is how it
works so you first train on the lingual
embeddings for one language so you train
German monolingual embeddings and
Englishman a lingual embeddings and then
you construct bilingual dictionaries so
you have a work at the the pairs of
English to German and then from those
bilingual dictionary you learn
transformation matrixes in such a way
that words in this bilingual dictionary
are maximally correlated and then you
map the original German and English
space to the shared space using those
transformation matrixes and then what
happens next is that right now this
Omega Omega star and Sigma star are in a
shared space and what you can actually
do is that you can map the transformed
German embeddings back to the English
space using the inverse of
transformation metrics of English and
what it actually allows us to do is that
right now we can map German to English
but then we can train it again for some
other land
this language to English and then all
the languages will be mapped to English
so we can support multiple languages at
the same time then so I told you what
kristincole embeddings are now I'm going
to show you a more visual example how we
train them so this is the bilingual
dictionary and you have lighter and
manager and engineer and engineer and
then you learn the transformation
metrics from this Paris and then you
haven't be clear in German this is a new
word that was not in the bilingual
dictionary and you map it back to the
English space using the transformation
matrixes that you learned and you hope
that it's gonna land somewhere close to
the developer in English there are
several ways how you can use for single
embeddings in your project so first
setup is the zero short parsing setup
this is when you do not have any German
data available so this is when you only
have English data and what you do is you
first train Englishman a lingual model
the way you would normally do so you
have English train data you use English
embeddings and then you train Englishmen
the lingual one oh and then during the
testing time you use projected German
embeddings to parse German cities
another case is joint training so this
is when you have some German data
available and what you do then is you
first combine English train data with
German train data then you use English
embeddings and project the German
embeddings to train the cross lingual
model and then during testing time you
do the same you just project the German
embeddings to parse German cities okay
so now I told you some theory behind it
and right now I want to share with you
some experiments that we've done because
we wanted to check whether transfer
learning works for us so this is our
experimental setup we wanted to parse
German series and we wanted to extract
job title and organization name from
experience section and embeddings we
trained our domain data we used word to
Vic and we used CCA to map them into the
same space which was in our case English
and we wanted to answer two questions so
first weather
transfer learning work for us and
we were also wondering whether bilingual
dictionary influences the performance so
you remember that I showed you this
bilingual dictionary from which we learn
the transformation matrixes and actually
if you tweak it a bit you will see now
that actually influences what you get in
the end so we had several experimental
setups so we had zero shot we used in
this experiment 3700 English series and
then we had joint training set up this
is when we combined English and German
data and you can see that we incremented
German data because we were actually
also interested in how adding more
German data influences the Cross lingual
gain the transfer gain that you get so
first question was just transfer
learning work for us and at the picture
you can see the gray bar plots they
represent the German baselines so those
were trained only on German data so you
see first 200 German series and 500
German series and then all the German
series we used in this experiment and as
expected the more German data you have
the better performance you get then the
blue bar plus they represent the Cross
lingual setup so first you see the zero
short parsing case and you actually see
that we get 75% f1 score in the zero
short case this is one we didn't use any
German data this is when we trained
Englishman a lingual model and then we
use Cross lingual embeddings in the test
time and this is actually not that bad
if you think about it and then we were
combining English data with German data
and you see that when we add 200 German
series the gain is 4% from the cross
lingual gain from the cross lingual
embeddings and then you add 500 German
series and then you get a little bit
less so basically what we can see from
this picture is that the more data we
have in the low resource language the
smaller becomes our trust in working ok
so the second question was how does the
bilingual
influences the downstream task
performance so first how can we actually
construct bilingual dictionary how can
we get it well you can use ready
bilingual dictionaries you can check out
the internet dictionary project but this
one it was created by volunteers and
actually it was not created for training
cross lingual embeddings this was
created just to make dictionaries
available for the Internet community so
maybe you might not want to use it and
if you have your language bear in the
Meuse Facebook project again so moose
they have 100 and bilingual dictionaries
they're four different language pairs
and this dictionaries they were created
specifically for developing and
evaluating for single embeddings so they
are already a bit of they have a bit of
a better quality but same as with free
training meetings the thing with
bilingual the Reggio bilingual
dictionary are is that they are trained
using wikipedia or news articles so they
gain quite generic and they might not be
the best and rewards for training the
metrics is for your domain so what you
can do instead you can construct your
own dictionary using your domain data so
what you need to do you first need to
choose english words in our case english
words and you need to consider several
things
so first filtering for example you might
not want to include stop words in your
bilingual dictionary then frequencies so
you might want to take top frequent
words or less frequent words and then
size so do you want to take one hundred
one thousand five thousand words and
then you can translate your selected
english words to german using Google
Translate API or Yandex Translate API or
any Translate API that you like and this
we conducted several experiments to see
which factors influence the downstream
test performance so here we checked how
the source of data of your bilingual
dictionary influence the performance and
we compared internet dictionary project
with news for capillary width and our
Seaver
capillary and what you can see here so
on the left side you see the joint
training case so this is when we used
all English data and then 200 German
series on the right side you see the
zero sort parsing case this is when we
only used English series to train our
model and then during testing time we
used for single embeddings and you see
that in both cases Civic AB you Larry
gave better results but in joint
training much less so than in zero short
parsing and by this I mean that actually
the difference between different
vocabularies in the joint training
doesn't matter that much but in the zero
shot parsing case you see that the
difference between EDP vocabulary and
the news vocabulary is around 10% and
then around 3% between use vocabulary
and Auntie vocabulary so in the next
experiment we were wondering how
frequency influences the downstream task
performance so we took either top 5,000
frequent words or we took from 5% to 10%
most frequent words so those were less
frequent words and the reason behind it
was that actually some researchers did
they showed that for single embeddings
they don't perform that well on less
frequent words so they thought that well
if maybe if we add less frequent words
into our bilingual dictionary and we
learn transformation matrixes from less
frequent words the results would be
better but they actually were not so top
frequent words they gave us better
results again both enjoin trading setup
and zero short parsing setup and again
in zero short parsing setup the
difference was much bigger and the last
experiment I'm going to talk about is
about size of bilingual dictionary so we
experimented with 1,000 5,000 and 10,000
words in the bilingual dictionary and we
saw that 5,000 to 10,000 they first of
all they gave almost the same result
both in joint training and 0 short
parsing so maybe you don't even need
10,000 maybe it's enough to have just
5,000 words and then we also saw that it
gives better results than 1,000
and again in zero short parsing the
difference between 1005 and 10,000 is
bigger than than joint training so our
experiments with bilingual dictionary
showed us that for construction
dictionary we need to use the main words
frequent words of size 5,000 and 10,000
and we also saw that the less training
data you have available the more
attention you need to pay to the
bilingual dictionary okay so now I
showed you how we trained our cross
lingual model and then how we set up our
bilingual dictionary and I would like to
share with you some examples of the
shared space that was trained using this
bilingual dictionary setup that I just
described so 5000 top frequent words and
domain vocabulary so these are examples
of words that were included in our
bilingual dictionary so English
administrator it was in the bilingual
dictionary and here you can see top
closest words for this English
administrator in our cross single-spaced
and you can see that among the German
neighbors you see admin and
administrator and system administrator
and IT administrator so those are all
good neighbors for English administrator
so we are pretty happy with this then
for English programmer which was also in
the bilingual dictionary you see German
neighbors such as developer programmer
software engineer etc so we see that
ultra single space captured the
semantics between English programmer and
German programmer
this are examples of words outside of
the bilingual dictionary so team later
it was not in the bilingual dictionary
so we didn't learn the transformation
matrix using it but still the neighbors
are pretty good so you can see that the
English neighbors of German team later
which is translated as team leader are
supervisor facilitator leader motivator
manager so those are all job titles and
this is actually what matters for our CV
parsing tasks
we actually don't really care if those
are exact translations of
simulator we just we just wanted to be
job titles because we only extract job
titles and we do not do any distinction
between what kind of job it is so
another example is Copenhagen in German
so it was not in the bilingual
dictionary again and you can see that
the English neighbors of Copenhagen are
Israel Netherlands and USSR and you
might think like well maybe those are
not the best neighbors but again they
are all locations and this is this is
what matters for our CV parsing tasks so
I think that everyone one that does this
kind of a relation of Christine will in
Beijing should keep in mind what kind of
tasks you are trying to solve so maybe
for your task this might not be the best
Christian world representation but for
us this is really good enough we wanted
to evaluate our Christine well-spaced
intrinsically and for that we created
the held outset on which we wanted to
test our words later on and persona here
which is personal in German appeared to
be there and we noticed a weird thing
actually personally he was not first
really well
it was parsed as name and it is not a
name and the reason for that is that
persona hang gaba which means personal
information probably it's it it occurs
often times with names and that's why
the neighbors of persona here the
English neighbors are presently they are
all English names and that is why it was
oftentimes mislabeled as name which
which is not good for us
you don't want persona hit to be a name
because it's not a name so what we did
we added persona here and other header
words from the CD work up to our
bilingual dictionary and we made sure
that they are all there and we retrained
out cross lingual embeddings and then we
actually got better cross lingo space so
you still can see some English neighbors
over there but now you can also see
words like personal or curriculum or
Europe a security
which are bachelors better neighbors for
personally and actually using this
Christine will space we now parse
personally correctly meaning that we
don't label it as name so I told you now
about all those experiments with English
in German language and you might be
wondering whether it also worked for
other languages well it does well it did
so we also did experiments with Dutch in
English and here you can see a very
similar picture as with English in
German so on zero short person we get
79% which is pretty good we didn't see
any Dutch data we only trained English
monolingual model and used Dutch English
per single embeddings and it got those
results and then you also see the
similar picture that as you add more
Dutch data the gain from Christine will
embeddings becomes smaller we also did
some experiments with Slavic languages
so we mapped check to Russian and and
polish to Russian and here on 0 short
case we got 84 percent for check and 81
percent for polish which is I think
that's amazing I mean we didn't see any
polish or Czech data we just trained the
model on Russian data and we already
Kate get 84 percent so what did we learn
from our experiment first transfer
learning works for our task we got
pretty good results and zero shot and we
also noticed that Christine will gain
reduces that as we add more data from
the target language and we also showed
that the quality of bilingual dictionary
affects the N task performance so the
less training data you have so in the is
your suitcase the more attention you
need to pay to the bilingual dictionary
and we suggest to use five top frequent
words in your domain vocabulary if you
want to get better result thank you for
your attention that was it
you